vergleich im vw diesel skandal geplatzt
volkswagen will seinen kunden trotzdem
entschädigungen zahlen
thüringer cdu chef zieht sich zurück
nach dem wahl-debakel gibt mike mohring
auch den vorsitz der landespartei und
thomas dreesen auf erfolgskurs nach dem
abfahrtssieg gestern rast der
skirennläufer beim super g in saalbach
erneut aufs podium
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg freitag der vierzehnte
februar guten abend und willkommen schön
dass sie dabei sind wie auch rudi cerne
für den sport hallo guten ab wir
beginnen mit wichtigen nachrichten für
vw diesel kunden zumindest für alle die
sich nach dem abgang skandal der
musterklage angeschlossen haben ein
vergleich zwischen vw und
verbraucherschützern ist zwar geplatzt
aber vw bietet den geschädigten trotzdem
geld an und zwar insgesamt 830 millionen
euro die voraussichtliche summe pro kopf
kann man in etwa schätzen denn laut vw
haben sich bis zu 470 tausend
geschädigte bei dem verfahren angemeldet
macht also eine einmalzahlung zwischen
1000 bis 6000 euro schon ab märz könnte
das geld an die kunden fließen
verspricht vw peter kunz heinrichs
dollar er ist einer der käufer von autos
des volkswagen konzerns für die die
verbraucherzentralen ihre klage
gestartet haben seit heute könnte er
geld bekommen 2000 euro vielleicht aber
von diesem angebot hält er gar nichts
volkswagen hatte am mittag die
vergleichsverhandlungen platzen lassen
und versucht sein eigenes entschädigungs
marketing autobesitzer sollen von der
klage abspringen und sich auszahlen
lassen dafür sind wir bereit ein
gesamtbetrag von 830 millionen euro zur
verfügung zu stellen
830 millionen für betrogene deutsche
diesel kunden auf diese summe hatten
sich der verbraucherzentrale
bundesverband und volkswagen prinzipiell
schon geeinigt nachdem das gericht beide
aufgefordert hatte sich um einen fairen
vergleich zu bemühen
der war heute plötzlich gescheitert über
den heutigen abbruch der verhandlungen
durch volkswagen sind wir irritiert
wir haben davon heute kurz nach 12 uhr
aus presseberichterstattung erfahren
leider ist auf den letzten metern eine
endgültige einigung daran gescheitert
dass der bundesverband der
verbraucherzentralen ein für uns nicht
nachvollziehbares unbegründetes
pauschalhonorar von 50 millionen euro
für seine prozessvertreter beute
überzogene nicht belegte
honorarforderungen bei den
klägeranwälten volkswagen sieht es so
und die gegenseite sieht einen bluff im
direct angebot an den kunden warten sie
und gehen sie keinen angeboten von
volkswagen nach die in den nächsten
wochen kommen werden schwere
entscheidungen für autobesitzer im
schnitt 2000 euro von volkswagen
kassieren jetzt sofort oder mehr geld in
ein paar jahren vielleicht denn das
verfahren gegen volkswagen wird sich
jetzt noch ziehen
mehr infos rund um den geplatzten
vergleich bei vw gibt es auf heute.de
dort finden sie einzelheiten zu den
entschädigungen und hintergründe zum
abgas skandal
ein weiterer rückzug in der cdu
in folge des wahldebakels in thüringen
hat nun auch landeschef mike mohring
angekündigt nicht mehr als
parteivorsitzender anzutreten
der 48 jährige stand schon länger intern
unter beschuss öffentliche
rücktrittsforderungen gibt es seit die
cdu gemeinsam mit fdp und afb den
ministerpräsidenten wählt
christoph distel berichtet twitter ist
für vieles gut so aber seinen rücktritt
ankündigen
da scheint zumindest ungewöhnlich doch
dafür hat sich mike mohring entschieden
keine nachfragen nur erklären und zwar
er werde sich als cdu-landeschef
zurückziehen ich glaube wir tun gut
daran dass wir unsere partei für frieden
dass die persönlichen interessen
zurückgestellt werden und dass wir zum
gemeinsamen weg für die zukunft finden
und ich möchte diesen weg nicht im wege
stehen und deswegen auch nicht erneut
für den landesvorsitz kandidieren
diese konkret mohring würde noch wochen
bis monate bleiben auch als
fraktionschef in einer extrem
zerstrittenen thüringen cdu geht das
manche nicht schnell genug
acht abgeordnete wollen dass er schon
nächste woche geht und so konsequenzen
zieht aus dem drama von erfurt rund um
die wahl von fdp mann kemmerich mit
stimmen von fdp fw und cdu gemeinsam die
partei ausgerechnet jetzt ohne
orientierung der frühere und gerne auch
kommende ministerpräsident ramelow von
der linken zeigt bedauern finde es
schade dass die cdu jetzt auf einmal so
auseinander läuft statt sich darüber zu
besinnen wie die aufgabenstellung sein
müsste
damit wir glaubwürdig den menschen in
thüringen sagen können wir gehen
gemeinsam ran das was am mittwoch
passiert ist jetzt auch stück für stück
wieder abzuarbeiten und was sagt die
chefin der bundes cdu zu moorings
entschluss immerhin mit ihren
vermittlungsversuchen in erfurt
abgeblitzt und deswegen inzwischen
selbst auf abruf ein kurzer kommentar
das ist die chance auf einen neuanfang
in thüringen kommende woche wollen rot
rot grün in erfurt eine lösung für die
krise finden ganz ohne cdu schwer
denkbar
in münchen hat die sicherheitskonferenz
begonnen mit rund 40 staats und
regierungschefs das wichtigste forum für
internationale sicherheitspolitik
bundespräsident steinmeier sagte in
seiner eröffnungsrede die welt verändere
sich in rasantem tempo
zum schlechten scharf kritisierte er die
usa china und russland der rückzug ins
nationale führe in eine sackgasse aus
münchen anne gellinek es ist so voll wie
nie auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
und das hat auch mit der düsteren
weltlage zu tun präsidentin außen und
verteidigungsminister drängeln sich in
den festsaal des bayerischen hofs
drinnen beklagt bundespräsident
steinmeier in seiner eröffnungsrede den
zerfall des westlichen bündnisses
er nennt donald trump nicht beim namen
die kritik am rückzug der usa aus
internationalen verträgen aber ist
deutlich sondern es sind rückfall in das
denken von fairen vorgestern und
erlauben sie es mir zu sagen es ist
brandgefährlich
doch steinmeier teilt auch gegen die
eigene regierung aus
deutschland müsse umdenken und aufhören
immer nur nein zu sagen ob bei
verteidigungsausgaben oder
militäreinsätzen der deutsche wir halten
uns vielleicht wie andere auch gerne für
die besten europäer handeln wird
wirklich immer so wie es unser reden von
des schicksals gemeint
europa eigentlich erfordern würde in der
europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik oder in fragen der
wirtschafts und währungsunion während
der bundespräsident deutschland
kritisiert kommt lob von unerwarteter
seite treffen der internationalen anti
terror koalition
der amerikanische verteidigungsminister
erfreut über das deutsche engagement
deutschland bleibt ein treuer
unterstützer im anti terror kampf mit
seinem bedeutenden militärischen
finanziellen und diplomatischen beitrag
so deutlich war steinmeier selten in
dieser unübersichtlichen welt lage komme
deutschland eine besondere rolle zu
nämlich die europa zusammenzuhalten das
aber könnte schwierig werden für eine
deutsche regierung die bis auf weiteres
mit sich selbst beschäftigt ist
es ist ein schwerwiegender verdacht eine
gruppe von rechtsextremen soll hier in
deutschland anschläge auf politiker
asylbewerber und muslime geplant haben
mit dem ziel bürgerkriegsähnliche
zustände herzustellen
der generalbundesanwalt ließ zwölf
männer festnehmen zuvor waren die
ermittler mit razzien in sechs
bundesländern gegen die gruppe
vorgegangen mehr dazu weiß felix
zimmermann aus unserer redaktion recht
und justiz felix gegen wen wird
ermittelt ja es wird gegen allesamt
deutsche staatsangehörige ermittelt
unter ihnen ist auch ein
verwaltungsbeamter aus nordrhein
westfalen
die täter kommen aus ost und west
insgesamt elf verschiedene landkreise
etwa münchen koblenz oder hand
und dazu passt dass die täter sich erst
im internet überhaupt kennen lernten
später kam es dabei auch zu persönlichen
treffen und seit september 2009 10 nimmt
die bundesanwaltschaft an das wirklich
eine terroristische vereinigung gebildet
wurde mit dem zierlichen mordanschläge
das politische system deutschlands kazi
anzugreifen
wie konkret waren diese pläne die
ermittler meinen dass noch keine
konkreten ziele und personen
festgestanden haben sehr wohl aber die
konkrete absicht durch mordanschläge
durchzuführen und die durchsuchung heute
die haben das bestätigt denn es gab ein
waffenfund
und einzel beschuldigte haben auch
ausgesagt und zwar eine aussage
getroffen die den tatverdacht erhärtet
und so konnten sie heute festgenommen
werden morgen geht es zum
ermittlungsrichter in karlsruhe und der
entscheidet ob die männer weiterhin haft
bleiben dankeschön für diese information
felix zimmermann und jetzt zu einem
ganzen katalog von neuen gesetzen den
der bundesrat abgearbeitet hat so soll
eine verurteilung wegen
kindesmissbrauchs künftig lebenslang
gespeichert bleiben
damit wird sie dauerhaft in das
erweiterte führungszeugnis aufgenommen
diese bestätigung braucht wer
ehrenamtlich oder beruflich mit
minderjährigen zu tun hat außerdem
sollen wichtige verkehrsprojekte künftig
schneller genehmigt und gebaut werden
und im straßenverkehr gibt es neue
regeln und höhere strafen auch um
radfahren sicherer zu machen
kloten leihen muss fahrradfahrer sollen
mehr platz bekommen autofahrer müssen
künftig beim überholen einen
mindestabstand einhalten ein meter
fünfzig in ortschaften und zwei meter
außerhalb zusätzlich gilt für lastwagen
mit ihrem riesigen toten winkel rechts
abbiegen innerorts nur noch im
schritttempo
sonst droht ein bußgeld von 70 euro das
parken in zweiter reihe wird empfindlich
teurer
autofahrer die auf markierten radwegen
stehenbleiben zahlen künftig bis zu 100
euro bußgeld führt es zu einem unfall
gibt es einen punkt in flensburg und ein
neues verkehrszeichen soll es geben ein
grüner pfeil nur für radfahrer
er erlaubt das rechtsabbiegen bei roter
ampel aber nur wenn man erst anhält und
niemanden gefährdet wo es für radler
besonders eng wird sollen sie besser
geschützt werden
dafür wird ein neues verbotsschild
eingeführt auto und lasterfahrer dürfen
hier fahrräder und andere einspurige
fahrzeuge nicht überholen
schärfere regeln für die mietpreis
bremse hat der bundestag beschlossen so
können mieter zu viel gezahlte miete
künftig bis zu zweieinhalb jahre lang
zurückfordern
außerdem wurde die regelung bis 2025
verlängert bei einer neuvermietung da
die miete nicht mehr als zehn prozent
über der ortsüblichen vergleichsmiete
liegen
neubauten sind ausgenommen gut eine
woche noch bis zur einzigen geplanten
landtagswahl in diesem jahr in hamburg
und es scheint als könnten dort spd und
grüne ihre koalition fortsetzen
laut aktuellem zdf politbarometer käme
die spd derzeit auf 37 prozent die cdu
auf 13 die grünen liegen bei 25 prozent
die linke bei 8 für die fdp wird es
danach wohl knapp mit 4,5 prozent die
fdp kommt auf 7 prozent
die meisten befragten sagen wahl
entscheidend sei die landespolitik vor
allem die verkehrssituation in der
hansestadt
gunnar koch berichtet wenn in hamburg
eine neue u bahn station eröffnet wird
ist das chefsache
aber nicht nur die spd mit bürgermeister
peter tschentscher sondern alle parteien
wollen den öffentlichen nahverkehr
massiv ausbauen
vielen bürgern aber reicht das nicht der
pnv soll auch billiger werden
drei stationen immer ein europäer
hervorragend es gibt hier keine
kurzstrecken und es ist relativ im
vergleich zu anderen großstädten teuer
hier
ich glaube dass ein jahres sicher ist
also einheitlichen preis für das ganze
jahr 365 euro im jahr eigentlich ganz
gut wären
für viele ist das bestehende angebot
nicht attraktiv genug
sie bleiben dem auto treu deshalb wurde
hamburg auch in diesem jahr wieder zur
deutschen stau hauptstadt gekürt die
bürger nervt
egal wie man unterwegs ist es stockt an
allen ecken und enden und ich denke das
ist ein wichtiger punkt dass man den
verkehr hier ins rollen bringt eine
großstadt ohne verkehrsprobleme experten
bewerten das als unrealistisch wollen
eine weltstadt sein zu einer weltstadt
gehört dichte und auch dichte stress und
auch leider stau ja man kann nicht
beides haben wollen weltstadt und den
verkehr von dinkelsbühl eine autofreie
innenstadt wünschen sich viele bürger
das aber verspricht keine partei die
große herausforderung wird es vielmehr
sein verkehr handel und umwelt in einer
modernen metropole unter einen hut zu
bringen
ein weiteres thema sorgt im finale des
wahlkampfs auch noch für wirbel
es geht um die im comex skandal schwer
belastete hamburger warburg-bank
medienberichten zufolge hatte es die
finanzbehörde 2016 versäumt millionen
steuerschulden der bank einzutreiben
zuvor habe sich der damalige
bürgermeister scholz mit dem chef der
bank getroffen
der bund der steuerzahler fordert
aufklärung die linke einen
untersuchungsausschuss bürgermeister
tschentscher weiß die verdächtigungen
zurück
34.000 mitarbeiter hat die
supermarktkette real viele fürchten um
ihre arbeitsplätze weil der
handelskonzern metro dem verkauf seiner
276 real-märkte angekündigt hat bis zu
30 filialen sollen geschlossen werden
wie es für die beschäftigten weitergeht
ist offen
in düsseldorf demonstrierten vor der
hauptversammlung des konzerns mehrere
hundert real mitarbeiter für ihre
arbeitsplätze
ein russischer finanzinvestor will den
größten teil der filialen an
wettbewerber wie kaufland und edeka
abgeben
eingesperrt auf wenige quadratmeter für
23 stunden am tag das klingt nicht
gerade nach traumreise sondern heißt
quarantäne realität seit tagen für
passagiere der
diamond princess vor yokohama auf ihrem
kreuzfahrtschiff gab es corona fälle
besser erwischen ist die urlauber auf
der ebenfalls unter infektionsverdacht
leiden denn westerdam das schiff dürfte
überraschend in kambodscha anlegen
normen odenthal selten ist die freude
ein kreuzfahrtschiff zu verlassen größer
als die freude ist zu betreten diesmal
schon
wir sind sehr glücklich hier zu sein
dank an die regierung kambodschas dafür
dass sie uns hat anlegen lassen jetzt
können wir nach hause
wir sind unendlich dankbar
es war ein langer harter kampf danke an
alle die uns geholfen haben ein harter
kampf eine lange irrfahrt für 2300
menschen darunter 57 deutsche thailand
taiwan japan gramm und die philippinen
alle hatten das schiff abgewiesen aus
furcht vor dem corona virus dabei wurde
keine infektion auf der wester dann
bestätigt gerüchte reichten auf der
diamond princess ist die lage ungleich
dramatischer
sie liegt weiter vom japanischen
yokohama in quarantäne
mehr als 200 virus infizierte wurden in
krankenhäuser transportiert alle anderen
müssen an bord bleiben
tatsächlich sehen ärzte auf schiffen ein
erhöhtes risiko und eine ganze reihe von
faktoren die dazu führen dass es
natürlich zu übertragung kommt ein
wichtiger punkt ist natürlich dass viele
menschen auf engem raum zusammenleben
das eben die hygienischen maßstäben
natürlich nicht so sind wie in einem
krankenhaus in sofern ist dann auch die
behandlung und auch die isolierung von
vielen erkrankten schwierig eine
kreuzfahrt durch asiens mehrere klingt
für viele gut kann in diesen zeiten aber
anders laufen als geplant dass corona
virus führt so manche traumreise in
unruhige gewässer beim wintersport ja
genau die deutschen biathleten sind auch
im zweiten rennen der wm in antholz in
südtirol ohne medaille geblieben
im frauen sprint kam denise herrmann als
beste deutsche auf platz fünf neue
weltmeisterin im norwegerinnen marke
rolls-royce land die ausgangsposition
ist für denise herrmann nach den zwei
schießeinlagen alles andere als gut
insgesamt drei fehler bei zehn schuss
doch hermann läuft eine farm
mose schlussrunde als die 31 jährige das
ziel erreicht hat sie eine hand dann an
der bronzemedaille
es folgen die wohl schlimmsten 20
minuten in ihrem sportlerleben hoffen
und bangen
am ende sind zwei athletinnen mit einer
höheren startnummer besser als die
deutsche rang fünf für mich top in
schuss aus der läufer aber mit drei
fehlern das ist natürlich dann schon
bitter weil ich schon gehofft dass es
für france reicht die neue weltmeisterin
aus norwegen martens gehäuse land
leistet sich nur einen fehler bei zehn
schuss gewinnt souverän ihr erstes
wm-gold im sprint auf rang zwei
überraschend die us amerikanerin susan
dank easy bleibt fehlerfrei
bronze geht an die tschechin lucie
safarova und in den eiskanal die
deutschen doppelsitzer tobias wendl und
tobias arlt sind zum auftakt der rodel
weltmeisterschaften aufs podium gefahren
die beiden olympiasieger aus
berchtesgaden wurde dritte im sprint
wettbewerb gold ging an russland silber
an italien auch in den sprintrennen der
männer und der frauen in sotschi gingen
die titel an die gastgeber deutsche
starterinnen und starter blieben ohne
weitere medaille und ski rennläufer
thomas dreesen ist einen tag nach seinem
dritten saisonsieg erneut aufs weltcup
podium gefahren
bei schon fast irregulären bedingungen
raste der 26 jahre alte dresen im super
g von saalbach hinterglemm auf der
aufgeweichten piste auf einen starken
dritten platz hinter dem schweizer mauro
caviezel und alexander ott gilde dem
norwegischen sieger und nun
gesamtweltcupführenden und da kann man
die korken knallen lassen mehr
wintersport morgen bei uns im zdf von 49
heute schon blumen gekauft
wieso erinnerung an alle verliebten
entdeckt an einer hauswand im englischen
bristol street art zum valentinstag ein
mädchen schießt mit einer schleuder rote
rosen an eine hauswand fuhr sie mit
rauem charme von baxi der weltberühmte
inkognito künstler aus brüssel hat sich
zu dem kunstwerk inzwischen im internet
bekannt
noch zum wetter das bringt dem norden
noch etwas regen sonst wird sonnig und
mild die details hat gleich gunther
tiersch marietta slomka spricht im heute
journal um 22 uhr mit
verteidigungsministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer morgen begrüßt sich hier
petra gerster wir danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ein schönes
wochenende
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau die zuschauer auf das wetter von
morgen kann man sich freuen es wird
nämlich aus dem südwesten jetzt deutlich
milder werden es gibt auch viel
sonnenschein die mehr als heute
jedenfalls und nur im norden bleibt es
stark bewölkt erst einmal ist er doch
ein bisschen regnen aber zum nachmittag
hin wird es dort auch freundlicher und
sonntag kommt nochmal wärmere luft zu
uns dann allerdings in norddeutschland
mit einem schweren sturm heute nacht
nach graz erst mal auf wenn die
regenschauer hier im südosten abgezogen
sind
es kann dann glatt werden wir erwarten
hier in der südhälfte noch einmal frost
zwischen minus 1 und minus fünf grad
das ist anders in norddeutschland milder
und in der zweiten nachthälfte wird es
an der nordsee anfangen zu regnen und
dieses regengebiet zieht vormittags
weiter erreicht auch die ostsee und das
emsland ja das lästern am späten
vormittag schon wieder nach hier und da
kommt vormittags schon in deutschland
die sonne raus vor allen dingen am
nachmittag da wird es dann richtig
freundlich
auch an den küsten wird's ein bisschen
heller und dazu weht allerdings dieser
kräftige ja süd bis südwestwind
bei den temperaturen geht es deutlich
nach oben also 10 bis 14 grad in der
westhälfte in der osthälfte so 8 bis 14
grad etwa 12 grad
insgesamt ja es wird dann am sonntag im
süden auch noch mal schön werden mit
temperaturen bis zu 19 grad aber selbst
im norden erwarten wir zwölf bis 17
dazu wird es im norden allerdings auch
regnen und da gibt es schwere sturmböen
in der neuen woche geht es dann
wechselhaft weiter ich wünsche ihnen
einen schönen abend und machen sie es
gut